STST 50 WERE10
ONE OF TSTIONSG OULD
AD BEC CRIMES?
O MAHIS RIN
HAPPEN.
HE JOINSE W FR
GORDAIN WHTH
IDEAYOKE A
NOT GOINTO
MIPUSOON
RHA IS
WAR  POLICY OFEINDUCTED BY PUTI
AL FAR
JUSTHE KINDSTHER VILLAGES
SOVE OALSAT ACT WITH
THE LE MONITPORT AND INVESTEROS
CRIMES.
E THAT THETHRLE.
AND I BELITHRINA
CASE TO CHARGEITA
KLTHREE TALKEDO ABOUTHTH SHOULD
SUET  TRIBUL.
D OB BE SEE HAGUONRNATIONACR
HUMANITY BUT THIS
CRE  AGGRESSIO T
E WH
1942 WHENTHATLDBECAME THE NURB
>> THEIFE TWN D ORHAT PE S YOU'
IS SOME KIND OF NEGOTIED NT. WD
DE    ENR,PANESEEG
GIG
PUTINT LIKELY MAKE SENSE T THI?
ONLY THINGNDBU'VE GO O N UNDERS
ST
Y SIGNAKEITHER DISUNITILLINGNESS
CAURER TDISPLAY STRENGTH
AND STRENGTH IYING YOU
ACT WITNITY
LY
O  EXTEND OTIME TO
WE , BU WE DO KNO THAT E'SION.
1942 THE QUESTION THENHO
CISH TT CLEARSE THATTHE CRIME O
LAW, UKRAINE
LAW, YOU MAKE IT CLEAR THA UNTRD
RET  R CIRCLET IF
F AGGRESSION WHICH MAT THERE IS
>>T DSE REG
EXAME,IS PERSONA NONECOMHACIRCU
MBE G  BE D IN SOME
E SULLIV IT
G2ANR THE
GL FRISHOULD RUSSIA ?
OF COURSE, RUSSIAN HAS OWOUWHA
GHSIERENFR PUIO
SPE E SIDELINES IN G20 AT TITA -
PAIPI N'ETS IN-PERSON.
D
G20 CA -ATOU Y
RUW IT WILREMAINPA STATEINECG OO
WE DON'T KNOW T  FINAL HINA WILT
THIS.
WHL WE'RE MOVINGE F
HAWHLY MIT TSSIA AND POTFUTURE
E TO CONTA
ECON A PIT ACTION ANTOGETHERR IS
THROUGH FREERA OR WHIT ME SURE
PEOP C
THE IA
OUNTRIF  WN WHEN HE T HA
D TH
-- IN YOF
IS NOWUKRAINS OPPORTUNISKELY?YO
FI
KNEW HE S
AND THE TH
SAYEARS S
MAIVR SIDE
T
ACTION WULD BETHERATINATION ON
DES IS E GOT TUNGT
THAT WANI'M AFRAID TY Y
L THE BANKD AND GAS SATI
NOT JUST SOME , AND WE
DEE PO